in the Clone Wars Ahsoka was known to
use her lightsabers to create improvised
entrances in the floral ceiling by the
time of Ahsoka she's honed this skill
into an art form an early cool moment in
the series premiere features Ahsoka
using the force to spin her lightsabers
around her cutting a hole in the ground
in order to enter a hidden chamber the
moment serves as a clear call back to
the Clone Wars but as it turns out it's
just the beginning when enemy droids
turn up and challenge her for the map
she just obtained she busts out the move
again by jumping back into the chamber
and literally undermining multiple
opponents by spin cutting the floor from
underneath their feet the smirk on her
face just before she pulls this off
reveals what a huge Flex this is it
seems that she's just delighted to find
an excuse to use her classic trick from
the Animated Series